[Music]
our next guest did a very cool thing
yesterday Paul Allen voice of the
Vikings and host of the 9:00 to noon
central show on KF a n made the trek to
a local hospital 45-minute drive I had
no idea I was imposing on his time that
much but one of the guys who is one of
the founding members of the group known
as the PFT p.m. Posse had emergency
surgery over the weekend perforated
ulcer twice ruptured appendix his name
is Tyler furnace and Paul went to see
him in the hospital and cheer him up
today is one of those days in life where
you're just blessed thank you Paul Allen
and pro football talk for going out of
their way to raise my spirits not only
with the Vikings member be really cool
the conversation was even better looking
forward to the next one so that was
great and all I had to do was ask Paul
to do it I really didn't do anything
Paul brought me in by FaceTime and I
talked to the guy for five minutes but
Paul is the one who's the hero here Paul
welcome in and thank you so much for
doing that yesterday you really helped
the guy at a you know a tough spot in
his life where he almost died literally
so thank you for doing that yeah what's
up buddy and you know I'm not certainly
not gonna pay myself as a as a hero here
I mean you you were the conduit to the
entire thing and you know it just did
just you know what I experienced
yesterday just just further exemplifies
what kindness can do for an individual
and the the the surprise factor of it
was though something that I drew a lot
of enjoyment out of it and you know I'm
really glad that you were able to
contact me over the weekend and let me
know what was happening to this young
Tyler got a charter member of the PFT
p.m. posse big fan of pro football talks
calm and PFT radio and the Minnesota
Vikings and so I went to the hospital
and I brought the Vikings were very
sweet to act quickly because the
Presidents Day nobody was in the office
you know and I wanted to get over there
then so they they were able to put
together an Derek Hendricks autograph
ball Kyle Rudolph and D Neil hunter
autographed pictures for this young man
and so then I went to the hospital North
Memorial and Maple Grove and I wanted to
surprise him but he wasn't in his room
when I got there so then I sat in the
room he came in and said Paul Howard
what the heck
and you know then we called you up on
FaceTime
I did a I did a mock interview with him
that's that his parents were able to
capture via video for about two minutes
and sat there and chatted with him
Viking football NFL Bella Jack stuff
like that for about 45 minutes he really
enjoyed it and it was not a pranced fire
it had you not contacted me over the
weekend so thank you well I appreciate
you doing it Paul it really was a great
gesture I'm surprised he didn't think he
was being visited by already laying
though that was really the I was hoping
I was hoping that that's what he would
think fairness and announcer act I
haven't cut my hair in three months that
I haven't shaved in a month and a half I
had a black coat on with black jeans so
he he probably thought it was just
somebody off the wintry streets of the
Twin Cities looking for a hot meal and a
warm place to sit but once he was able
to uh see through the Artie Lange guys
he quickly recognized something very
cool was happening and and yeah he was
really really excited and it you know
and following some things that people
were saying on Twitter yesterday it just
further exemplifies the power of the PFP
family and you know how whether it's
Kirk Cousins here Antonio Brown and mr.
big chest and you know things taking
place around the country how people can
crack wise and be snarky but when you
pull it all back for just a second you
recognize what really matters most and
that was yesterday
power folks in Minnesota handling the
aftermath of what all only was a
disappointing season well it's quiet now
you know we in my radio show and
certainly all the teams heading to the
Scouting Combine next week you know we
were we're starting to look at certain
offensive linemen for certain teams and
you know when I do open the phone lines
and then take off these the suggestions
you don't you don't really hear a lot of
a lot of zany things I mean the the the
eight seven and one was Bible Asst you
know we we had some bad moments we
didn't have very many good moments and
and the highly compensated quarterback
statistically speaking was good but
there were pick sixes and fumbles and
you know people are kind of negative on
him so I you know I think they just I
think the fan base just wants to see it
retool
and see where it goes get to the
organized team activities training camp
preseason and try it again
okay one of the I don't know how many of
your listeners raise these concerns if
you've been paying any attention to what
we've been talking about here you know I
have some concerns about the value the
Vikings are getting for the quarterback
that they signed last year two or three
or 84 million dollar contract what can
you say to me if anything to get me to
buy in for a second year of Kirk Cousins
well it falls you know when and I do
follow pro football TOCOM and your work
every single day and I listen to your
radio show most days on my driving to
work so you know whether it's Kirk or
Kirk or the problems that you're at
understand it falls in line with the I
understand but I don't agree and then
where I don't agree is clearly there
were some philosophical problems with
the Vikings offense last year you know
an offense that went a large part of the
season without Dalvin cook yeah so much
so that the offensive coordinator had to
be fired so now they burn they bring in
Kevin's to phanpy they've hired Gary
Kubiak as an offensive despiser you know
and chatting privately with Mike Zimmer
about the way things are developing
offensively with with these beatings and
the vision for next year and everything
he's unbelievably excited and and I have
I have not heard Mike talk about and awe
and offensive coaching staff the way he
does now and you know what what he likes
about Gary and Kevin specifically those
two is that their ego break and and it
does not it does not have to be their
way or the proverbial highway so now
with cousins you know you take that
season you just saw the warts you saw
the good things and and you move into
the next season and this this is the
money season because there is stability
up to the season there will be stability
during the season you know you you talk
about the the the death of Tony Sparano
right into the season that was massive I
mean that there are two coaches on this
staff Tony Sparano the late Tony Sparano
and defensive line coach John Gray
Patterson who have the
- eh - sit across from Mike Zimmer and
really really get through to him about
how things are going and offensively
with a new coordinator in John D
philippa they lost that and that was
absolutely massive you know for the for
the the time that it happened so I
understand where you're coming from I
know exactly what you're talking about
but this next season is incredibly keen
for Kirk how do they end up addressing
their needs though with so much money
invested in Kirk Cousins we've seen
plenty of young key players get
long-term deals and I'm sure some guys
are gonna have to walk away because of
it including maybe Anthony bar via free
agency but how do they improve the
offensive line for example when there's
so much money tied up in other positions
excellent question specifically looking
at the names available via free agency
you know and the the cap money or lack
thereof the team currently has I I do
believe that there there is a chance
that there could be some rather
prominent names that aren't on the team
next year you you mentioned Anthony bar
you know when the when the Vikings did
did a new deal with Eric Kendricks you
know he's I can't believe that they
would do a deal with Kendricks and not
try to get one done with bar at the same
time so I'm guessing that they did and
and bar and his representation wanted to
wait to pre agency so now you know
there's a fascination with Anthony
around the NFL I believe that that he
can be a stand-up outside linebacker and
a three-four defense and do nothing but
like Von Miller stuff and rush the
passer well we'll see if that can happen
you know so I'm not saying a camp but
I'm certainly not saying it will so if
that's the case then somebody's going to
give him money so that the Vikings are
not going to be able to spend you know
there are other prominent names who may
not be on the team next year so they can
find money who but who with their
weather grew up with their draft picks I
I have to imagine two of the first three
draft picks go on offensive linemen
specifically 18 overall and those two
guys might have to play and play me
immediately all right who else may not
be there you're trying to avoid the
question is is Everson Griffin going to
be gone well I'm not as contractually
sound as you are when it comes to like
dead money and stuff like that honestly
I find it quite boring that it's wait
for it to happen then I react
it ampersand Griffin would be the most
prominent name that's the one that's
bandied about most locally and or
nationally you know there um there was a
situation with Everson last year where
he had to leave the team for a month in
change and and you know they also have a
defensive end in Stephen Weatherly who's
getting better stride by stride along
with daniil hunter and they have the
draft so that that could be that could
be a prominent name they're very deep at
corner they have Xavier Rhodes Trey
Wayne's Mike Hughes Mackenzie Alexander
jumped out of his skin last year and
this undrafted cat named Holton ill
ended up being really good so you know
Trey's heading into the final year of
his deal and with all due respect to
everybody I thought he was the best
corner on the team last year so Xavier
is set to make ten and a half million
dollars you know it is that money they
feel they can use this offseason would
they consider trading him I don't know
if they would but uh but they have to
find a route to cap money some out how
is it that Rhodes is always hurt but
he's always able to play great question
it's been the situation with with Xavier
since since he's been here you know he
he something will happen and he'll go
down like he was shot and then then
he'll miss a few plays and you'll pop
back well Xavier is topped by a corner
in the NFL when he's out being happy but
again you know there are uncomfortable
decisions that need to be made to find
roots just our II got money and you know
the the cousins three and eighty four
guaranteed it definitely plays into that
but you know you you know the way you
look at Kirk from last year I understand
the thing that's bugging me most about
Kirk right now is is his incessant
tweeting and and if I were cousins
I would lay off Twitter man and I don't
know if he has a marketing firm kind of
guiding him as to what to do on Twitter
to like craft his image or whatever his
image is crafted his family is perfect
he has tons of cash he's the National
Football League quarterback and like
last week he went on Twitter and with a
kind gesture saying okay I'm gonna give
away an autographed football jersey or
picture what do you want if you look
through the mentions the the savagery
that he was seen what would have made
Hannibal Lecter blush and and then it
happened
and earlier this week when he talked
about being in Miami so a I think her
cousin's just needs to forget about
Twitter for a little bit focus on the
offseason and then come back strong Paul
that is the harshest I've ever heard you
yeah so if we were off the air if we
were off the air it would be even
stronger than that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports